is there somebody in your life close to
you that that you trust enough to call
you out on your [ __ ] we're all full
of [ __ ] sometimes
what's my [ __ ]
well some of it I pointed out today but
I don't know you deeply enough what was
the book Jewish media Jewish that's not
[ __ ]
the [ __ ] is that the Jewish people
won't admit your dad was right your dad
was right the words you used the you
weren't the point you said it you're not
gonna make me say it 800 more times
I don't know if it resonated because you
keep saying like the words did it
resonate to y'all that y'all ain't do
nothing about it and that all y'all want
to do is have somebody apologize and
sweep under the rug your [ __ ] that
you've been doing the whole time you're
on the same [ __ ] as the other people
so you're doing the same thing that the
other let's say media because I'm not
allowed to say has done so until
somebody which is what man it's just
what is I'm trying to call you out in
your [ __ ] because I hope I'm
somebody you can trust I don't [ __ ]
trust you
well you should find people in your life
you can trust don't tell me what I
should do I'm not one of your BLM
Marchers listen I'm with you on the BLM
a lot of organizations use tragedy it
and
um and I watched the Candace Owens
documentary
and what was your take on it
I think it's important to question the
mainstream narratives but I don't agree
with it I still believe that George
Floyd
uh died
from the knee of the cop
not from fentanyl